yo what's up everybody it's
international master Daniel wrench we're
back again today on chest coms YouTube
channel I hope you enjoy this weekend
feature I wanted to bring you the next
most logical installment in our chess
openings playlist after the nimzo-indian
that being the Queen's Indian why is the
Queen's Indian the next most logical
installment after the nimzo-indian well
after d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 the main move
as you learn from our video a few days
back this week the nimzo-indian after
Knight to c3 is Bishop to b4 of course a
moves such as d5 would transpose back
into a Queens gambit or Queens gambit
declined but that's not really the
subject you can find videos on the
Queens gambit and Queens gambit declined
in our chess openings playlist in fact
but that's not our subject so a
transposition is possible but if white
doesn't allow the nimzo-indian with this
move Knight to c3 the other main option
for white is to play this move Knight to
f3 and in this position there are
several ways for black to play we're not
covering all of them right now but to
mention them there's the move c5 after
d5 Black has options of capturing and
transposing into a benoni opening a
benoni structure there's also the
options of b5 which is the bloomenfeld
gambit maybe not considered a main light
option about 20 years ago but certainly
is now very popular way for black to
play and the other way for black to play
rather than c5 would be the move Bishop
to b4 check and after several moves out
possible here for white Bishop to d2
Knight B to d2 Knight to c3 which
transpose back into animal Indian but
after those few moves Knight bTW 2a
Bishop d2 we have a move such as Queen
to e7 which is the BOGO Indian or the
old Indian depending on what you want to
call it those those tend to transpose
with each other again those are not the
subject of today's video but rather the
Queen's Indian kind of funny how we have
so many names right the King's Indian in
Queens India were not slave trades in
Europe okay despite what you may be
thinking totally joking about that a
offensive joke I heard one time from
somebody else so I'm doing the world a
favor to pass it on here but let's get
back to the chest in any case they
our mainline openings and b6 is an
opening is a way for black to approach
White's neglect of bringing this Knight
to c3 why does b6 make sense
because by freeing up the square for the
bishop to come to b7 or in some cases a6
what black is doing is potentially
preparing to get grab control over the
light squares in the center for example
after the move g3 which is the main move
for white black has two main moves
Bishop to b7 and Bishop to a6 one main
line that goes Bishop to b7 Bishop to g2
Bishop to e7 notice how the main point
of white is is that he's neglecting
developing this bishop here again to
avoid the natural pin by the bishop
which would lead to nimzo-indian
positions what he's doing what he's
giving to black in exchange for that is
potentially better control over the
central light squares and after the move
castles castles now white might play the
move Knight to c3 as black has already
lost the tempo with this move Bishop d7
and there are several ways to block for
black to play but one of them is the
move Knight to e4 which is a natural way
to play and black might follow that up
with a move like f5 increasing his
control over this efore square preparing
potentially to play a move like d6
Knight be d7 and Knight f6 to bring
another Knight behind to support the
center black can also play the move d5
here at some point and another way that
would support his knight in the center
though it does block the bishop
temporarily the tension that exists
between these two fianchettoed Bishop's
one being on the Kings side one being on
the Queen side is definitely something
that defines the Queen's Indian as
potentially white will try to play it
sometimes moves like d5 with the idea
being that for example if we make a move
here random move for black a move like
d5 increases White's control over the
center and prepares a movie for to
really maintain a grip and after black
takes it those moves such as Knight h4
unleashing a pin along the diagonal and
preparing to recapture the pawn upon the
next move these are a common pawn break
in the center a common type of tactical
tension that exists in the Queen's
Indian the main idea here for black
besides Bishop to b7 the other main idea
is this move Bishop day6 in this case
what black is doing is
trying to put pressure along the
diagonal the white is sort of neglecting
and leaving behind with this idea of
Fein Kettering a bishop after the move
Bishop a6 is a few ways for white to
play one of the main ways for white to
play is let's move Queen to c2 that
defends the pawn after which black will
typically play this move Bishop before
check there are others but this is the
most natural this move makes sense now
because the move Knight to c3 would be
not not necessarily transmission in the
nimza but rather potentially just a loss
of the pawn as developing the night here
blocks the Queen's protection of the c4
pawn and the move Bishop to d2 which is
another natural move here would be met
by Bishop d7 you might think why would
black waste a temple like this but a
typical idea is that the bishop on d2
sort of fights this Knight for the
square in the sense that White's pieces
are fighting each other over the right
squares doesn't want to develop the
knight here as black might capture it
developing the Knight to c3 blocks the
Queen and therefore unprotected C for
pawn and if you can't develop the Knight
to c3 or a3 then at some point white
will also have to lose a temple with
this bishop in order to free the square
for the knight so this move Bishop d7
after the movie for which is a natural
way for white to play and try to grab
the center and punish black's loss of
time d5 captures here Bishop takes f1
ruining White's right to castle but
White's okay he's going to cancel by
hand you might see a line like this
occur in which case that the natural
play tends to occur with white fighting
for the C file black has a pretty good
grip on the light squares and white has
to catch-up in terms of time as his King
is is castling by hand it's a pretty
dynamic and interesting game and you can
check it out if you want to know more
about the variations here you can use
our database search and master games
explore on our main site on the main
subjects comm but this would be an
introduction to one of the main lines of
the Queen's Indian the other main line
to defend the c-4 pawn instead of Queen
to c2 is to move Knight bTW to after
which again you'll see a common idea
that repeats not only in the Queen c2
variation after white played efore
remember of likely d5 in this situation
again black and play for d5 and after
something like captures captures Bishop
g2 Bishop d6
we start to see a common recurring theme
in the terms of this Bishop a6
development in the Queen's Indian black
trying to strike at the center with d5
in order to just
by this development by creating pressure
along the diagonal here white once black
wants to play the move rook e8 and
potentially even pop a knight in to e4
white many cases will play the move
Knight to e5 here which is a strong move
and after something like rook e8 you can
even see tactics like Knight to c4
exposing the pin along the diagonal the
game is very interesting and dynamic and
probably roughly equal and again you can
check out and use game explorer searches
and in games databases you can access
online to see more about that line the
other way to defend the pawn is the
movie 3 and again we see a similar
circumstance with white having to deal
with black strike against the c4 pawn
again if you see this capture here
you'll see a natural type of plan for
black with getting castled and trying to
use the e-file and potential pressure
here on the open open diagonal with the
rook and Bishop working together and
again you see white at some point trying
to use the squares in the center for his
pieces as well as exert pressure along
this diagonal against blacks exposed
light scores on the Queen side
so in review I would say that the
Queen's Indian is a main weapon it's
it's it's a main way for black to play
against White's approach to decide to
avoid the NIM so this idea of b6 in your
in your mind and blacks attempt to
control the light scores whether it be
with the Bishop a6 development and
strikes with d5 or with the Bishop to b7
development and early assertion of the
knight and potentially f5 as I showed
you keep the Queen's inning in mind as a
way to counteract White's choice to
avoid the nimzo-indian I hope you
enjoyed this and there are lots more
videos on this type of subject and end
games like this on our main site and
hope you're enjoying our YouTube channel
hope you enjoyed this video and we'll
see you around
on chess calm